garyvee what's up Louis house here from
the school of greatness podcast big fan
of the askgaryvee show
keep it up love what you're doing I've
got a two-part question for you and it's
geared around selling books I've got a
big book launch coming out in October
and the fall it's called the school of
greatness very excited about it and I've
got two-part question for you one with
Instagram ads looking like they're gonna
be opening up here soon somebody's
paying attention you could always spend
money in one place on ads Facebook or
Instagram where would you be putting
your money on a book launch coming out
this fall that's part one
in part two if you were looking to get
10,000 pre-orders through bulk orders
where would you be focusing your energy
and efforts to get 10,000 pre-orders
piece of cake because I've done it so
that's how much yourself you like it
thanks I love that Louis I would I'm
hedging here because I just don't know
exactly what Instagram is gonna do if I
knew that Instagram is gonna fully open
up the funnel the firehose and ads are
just rolling in and we're seeing five
seven ads a day on our feed then I would
say Instagram
I really would cuz I do believe the
attention is sitting in Instagram the
problem is my intuition without any
knowledge is there gonna be a little
tighter on the spigot and it's gonna be
a little tougher to actually break
through and so I would spend 50 cents on
a dollar in Facebook and Instagram the
problem is your books coming out in
October the app proper I'm supposed to
come out in October my belief is it
comes out later so I think I want you
mentally in facebook facebook is gonna
dominate number two choose a piece of
cake because I've done it multiple times
and I'll do it again in March or
February for my scary be book the place
to go is to your homies the place that
goes to your homies what I mean by that
is reverse engineer everything you've
done for people for the last 18 months
and send them one by one
not in bulk biggest mistake people make
is send a bulk email and say this is the
one time I want to send a bulk email you
know I I just need all of you to buy my
book I get that all the time that is a
piece of crap execution it will not work
I don't feel like it's personal I never
buy but Luis when you email me and you
write a whole thing like hey remember
when we first met in Ohio and I drove
you around or st. Louis and I
drove you around and this and that and
you know thanks for being on my podcast
and hey remember a couple months ago you
I asked this question on the show so
here's my thing and hey it was great to
see that like real stuff like real stuff
like the party in LA that I have like
real stuff real stuff that happened
between you and I not a bulk ctrl-c
ctrl-v
this is you and me you spent five
minutes writing this email it would
really mean a lot to me I'm gonna be
guilted into buying 100 bucks
and that's it and you've got a lot of
people like that and some people are
even more homey with you know by a
thousand or they'll buy 40 Orla by 90
and literally when when Jab Jab right
hook came out in that August that came
out in February in that August or not
came it when did it come out and Jan I
don't wanna judge a right hook of it
anyway in that August maybe December
anyway in that August I emailed
thousands of people one by one wrote
them one by one emails it took forever
and I got a lot of sales and well into
the tens of thousands and so that would
that's exactly what I would do I'd
reverse-engineer CRM your whole social
graph the 25 to 7,000 people that most
matter and one by one by one remind them
the nice things you've done I know how
you roll you build up leverage one by
one by one one by one by one one by one
by one
tedious long an effort that converts an
actual sales and follow up I went in
right in a be like look you need to say
no in this email or at the time Nate
who's a CEO of the book or Nate is gonna
email you and ask you every week on the
week and I'm cool [ __ ] if you go with no
cuz I get it
cool but you need to say it because I
will bother you until you tell me and so
put them in a corner suffocate them
don't let them be able to like just
delete it and not answer pound them let
them basically understand that you will
not have a relationship going forward if
you don't at least answer and that know
is equally as awesome as a thousand and
that's what I did
I really made everybody feel very
comfortable and saying no because I get
it as I did with them being a thousand
it's funny after I did a Jab Jab right
hook even though I did it for crushed
and Thank You economy after I did it for
Jab Jab right hook it's funny I've been
giving this advice to a lot of people
and as you guys know we've been buying a
lot of hundreds and to hundreds and
putting them out for Bainer
so that's the scoop my man that's what I
would do